so did you hear Carl Bernstein go on CNN
to say the president's increasingly
unstable it was a special day on CNN
they call it Monday also Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday and
Sunday what all of this becomes more and
more is considerable evidence building
that we have a fundamentally corrupt
president who is a danger to the
national security has undermined our
democratic system and is also
increasingly unstable that was a
formerly famous reporter who used to
look like Dustin Hoffman commenting over
the shocking appearance of another
whistleblower to follow the first one
that didn't quite work out actually he
really did blow the dams in media are
like 3d printers they create the
whistleblower mold so they're made to
order like an omelet station and then
like actual was whistleblowers the only
risk here is writers cramp from inking
their first book deal and what would
Carl do if it weren't for Trump worth
CNN he'd be on a street corner in a
bathrobe made of news clippings holding
a sign that said everything is worse
than Watergate what we are watching in
the Trump presidency is worse than
Watergate I keep getting asked are there
echoes of Watergate in this and there
are we're also witnessing something we
did not see in Watergate which is a
meltdown by a president who is
demonstrably unhinged what we're seeing
is worse than Watergate now it's not his
fault CNN puts him on it's the news
carousel for the befuddled
remember that playground carousel is a
kid you got on the thing go ahead going
with a few pushes from your foot then
round and round it went
that's the media business model they get
this story started and up to speed then
add the same old faces
nothing like David Gordon talking to
Gloria Borger do you feel like you're
getting the latest news from the golden
acres card room from four old hacks with
free afternoons it beats feeding the
pigeons and if it weren't for Carl it'd
be somebody else that shouty lawyer that
shouty ex-agent the shouty former
republican that shouty consultant who
needs work further proof though that a
trump economy raises all boats including
the dinghies of his dopiest critics
got a good laugh out of that one Jesse
when he says I keep getting asked is
this worse than Watergate he keeps
getting asked by Anderson Cooper hotels
like yeah look at the transcript there's
no burglar we had a burglary yes and I'm
using Watergate like that get out of
your mouth listen folks been under
permanent investigation for three years
at this point they can't get the guys
bulletproof at this point and if he
cooperates he's guilty if he doesn't
cooperate he's guilty he can't win so
what does American are gonna do they're
gonna have one anonymous CIA agent
overturn the will of 60 million people
that's not gonna fly in this country and
to make Adams shift the face of
impeachment is a huge miscalculation
Adam Schiff is like the justice Millette
of John Brennan's he's got no
credibility
he's totally compromised and everything
he says no one believes at this point
and I do want to do a mini deep dive
into the deep state because I have some
new information you guys lawyers for the
whistleblower used to work for the
Southern Poverty Law Center the ACLU
Hillary Clinton and Chuck Schumer the
other lawyer for the whistleblower is
being advised by John Podesta Hillary's
campaign manager and the actual
whistleblower himself not only is he a
registered Democrat but he has a
professional relationship with one of
the Democrats running against Trump in
20 just a coincidence Jesse that's just
a coincidence
what happens if Karl actually find
something that is worse than Watergate
then his whole career is over I'll
forget it forget it I feel like as I'm
watching that I'm like isn't that the
Russia collusion it's just on loop over
at CNN it's the same thing it's like
let's let's decide that somebody is this
guilty before we've even seen a
transcript I mean you had Nancy Pelosi
calling for an impeachment inquiry she
hadn't even seen the transcript at all
she's not embarrassed it's it's this
willingness to convict on day one and
that's that's the big issue really not
that Democrats are saying okay someone
has come forth we want to investigate it
okay those are your investigations the
problem is that they decide even before
they do that investigation and the Trump
is guilty of x y&z and then when you
have the transcript of the call and you
look at it and you say okay I have two
pairs of functioning eyes and there is
no quid pro quo there is no
there is no exchange where Trump says
you're laughing won but there is no
point in that call where he says okay if
you do this for me I will do this for
you then you still have people who will
distort and say oh no but you can infer
this is when you're talking about
impeachment impeachment is serious I'm
not interested in your inferences I'm
interested in what's actually on the
call and the facts and it would be great
if someone journalism work yeah I want
to pivot now to the letter from the
White House to Congressman John Kasich
and Don Lemon oh you know we can save
that for tomorrow I love me some lemon
but you know the thing is this is an
interesting letter Paige to Dana there's
this part where they go
in addition Greg Gutfeld has been a
tremendous asset to Fox News he deserves
a large raise and should probably have
an entire day just devoted to himself
maybe all of Sunday can't believe they
buried that on page two you know why I
know what you thought some letter and
then one I love letters I like when
lawyers write really great letters I
love that way this is an excellent
letter I think will be taught in law
schools well really if it's worse than
Watergate yes they do there'll be even
as footnotes and everything yeah but
notes I find footnotes to take ups makes
it very official though I think it's a
pretty well written letter because they
lay out a very specific case they say we
do not the Republicans have co-equal
subpoena power we've been denied due
process we can't cross-examine we can't
look at evidence and the person running
the investigation has been tainted and
compromised and we don't trust him and
then they're threatening State
Department employees with docking their
pay if they don't comply not with the
subpoena but with just a request and
they say it's such a grave
undertaking impeachment that this can't
be done in the dark
all right whine over here I listened I
listened with interest to my colleagues
I still wait for substance I mean that
idea hammer the table on some process
because the facts stand against you
that's what a lawyer note learns in in
law school basically Trump is blocking
today tells diplomat oh you can't
testify after being a midnight call
you can do that a diplomate slur oh no
we don't want him to testify even though
the guys already flying here he can
always delay distraction and of course
demonize Joba but it's not obstruct this
was the perfect call if this was so
perfect oh then why can't anyone talk
about it
by the way Jedediah no no no Trump says
he doesn't want anybody to talk to
congressman because I let you go on and
on
Jedediah when he says we've been very
kind to the Ukraine and I'm asking you
for a favor and the timeline suggests
that he blocked the eight a week before
me but you'd say when you're talking
about someone oh he doesn't want to
testify the guy who said the president
has been crystal clear we have text on
the Restylane in which Sandlin is saying
to Bill Taylor let's not talk about the
quid pro quo cos you know we should do
this pressure and he's a big Trump donor
but let me get back to what we got if we
got to go to the head I want to tell you
about your point because to me you're
the I can say me about me having my on
the show on the resident would use
federal money to extort a foreign
government is far bigger than breaking
an entry in the Watergate Hotel oh this
is bigger than Watergate question that
using a foreign government to interfere
is bigger than what we saw in terms of a
breathing here oh my god why not we have
other people on the show and in the
Washington Post poll today for the first
time what you see is 28% of Republicans
saying they support this impeachment
inquiry 18% of Republicans saying remove
this president of Republicans saying
it's necessary for Democrats to take a
stand against that it is starting to see
Republicans as Colin Powell said get a
grip yeah and that is the direct result
of a media and it and the and the
Democrats teaming up together that
deciding guilt rating arrogancy before
the end that's what it's all about
creating a narrative